-The password is..."bunny."
[ Laughter ]
-Alright.
We'll start with you, Bob.
-Uh. Big ears. Oh, can I use
two words or one word?
-You know what? You can.
[ Laughter ]
-Wait a second.
-Well, come on.
-You've had a...
[ Laughter ]
-Mickey Mouse.
-No.
-Bradley.
-Alright.
-Okay.
Easter...
-Bunny.
-Whoa!
Whoa!
♪♪
Alright. That was a warmup.
-Don't worry about it.
That was good.
a-That was a warmup.
This is round two.
Fast and furious.
-The password is...
-This one I'm gonna get.
-Got it.
-I'm gonna get this one.
-Ooh.
-Okay. Your turn, Bradley.
-Oh, it's my turn?
-Yep.
-Bradley goes first.
-Hmm...
-You can do it. You can do it.
-Okay. Uh --
And no gestures?
-No gestures.
-Okay.
-This is not charades.
-Why'd you have to ask that now?
Yeah. No gestures. Nice try.
-It's called pass word,
not pass gesture.
-Uh...uh...
Uh, lick.
-Tongue.
-Mnh.
[ Laughter ]
-No!
-"Sicle."
[ Laughter ]
-Pop?
-Ehh...
-Sicle?
-Bradley, your turn.
-Um, okay. So -- Okay.
-Alright.
-Um...
[ Chuckles ]
Uh. Uh, uh, um.
[ Laughter ]
Uh. Oh, geez.
Oh, a candy.
-Cane.
-Ooh.
[ Laughter ]
-Loosen it up.
Remember the clues, Jimmy.
-Uh, okay.
"Ah, la-la-la..."
[ Laughter ]
-Come on.
-That's a gesture!
That's a gesture!
-That was a song.
It was a song.
-Uh, uh. Ice.
-No!
-Ice is not a candy.
-Okay. Forget -- We missed
that one. I screwed up.
-We missed it?
-No, no.
You can get 2 points.
-Bradley goes now.
-2 points. Bradley.
It's your turn, Bradley.
-Okay, okay. [ Laughs ]
Uh, uh...
Lolli...
-Ohh!
[ Buzzer ]
[ Sad tuba plays ]
I meant to say, "What's up?"
-Lollipop.
-Wait. Do we get it, then?
-Judges?
-[ Buzzer ]
-Oh, no.
-It's all good.
-No, that's alright.
-Alright. So it's 5-0.
-I totally messed that up.
-Jimmy?
-Here we go.
-I so messed that up.
-That's alright. It's okay.
-The password is...
-Jimmy, we're going to start
with you.
-Okay.
I think this word's hyphenated.
It's one word.
Hyah!
[ Laughter ]
-Karate?
-Yes!
[ Bell dinging ]
♪♪
Yes! 6 points!
We got the lead! Whoo!
-Wow! It is a barn burner!
It is a barn burner.
There you go, Jimmy, Smeeta.
Smeeta, it's your turn.
-The password is...
-It's not a bong burner.
-Was it bong burner?
-I thought you said --
-No, I said "barn burner."
-Okay.
-I should've said bong burner.
[ Laughter ]
-Spaghetti.
-Western.
-Ooh.
-Hm, Sergio Leone called.
-I thought that's what
you meant. I'm sorry.
I'm the worst at this game.
-Mama's.
-Um...sauce.
-Smeeta.
-Sauce.
-Gravy?
[ Laughter ]
-That's what they call sauce
in Philly. Gravy.
-Spaghetti...
-Meatballs?
-Yes!
[ Bell dinging ]
-Whoa. Okay.
-Meatballs!
-Come on. You can catch up.
-Yes! I'm very excited!
"Spaghetti western."
-You know what --
-Gosh.
The score's Dolly Parton.
9 to 5.
-Oh, my God.
We can add groans in post.
-The password is...
-Bob, you're going to give.
-Here we go.
-Okay.
-Um...
Jack.
-Jack.
[ Laughter ]
[ Buzzer ]
-Oh.
-Ohh.
-Alright, Bradley.
-Okay.
-You could tie the game.
-Let me just make sure
I don't repeat the word.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
Tree.
-Green.
-Green. No.
-Tall.
-Beanstalk.
[ Bell dinging ]
[ Laughter ]
You are the best.
We make a good team!
You guys, we are the champs!
-The password is..."Rihanna."
[ Laughter ]
-Don't look, Tariq.
Abbi?
-I go first?
-Why don't you start us off?
Yeah, absolutely.
-Okay.
-All right.
-Yep. Right.
Oh, they're getting in there.
-[ As Rihanna ]
♪ Diamonds ♪
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughter continues ]
-I don't know, man.
That's over.
-Why did you say it like that?
[ Laughter ]
Rihanna.
-Oh, my gosh! Come on!
That was great!
Oh, my goodness!
Give me that.
Didn't even get a chance, man.
All right. I'm gonna give the
next clue to Rocky and Tariq.
Here you go. Best of luck.
-The password is...
-Tariq?
Tariq, you are up first.
-All right. Okay.
Stuffed.
-Dumpling?
-Yes!
♪♪
-That was good!
"Stuffed" was the jam!
-That was good.
-...Wu-Tang reference...
-Sorry about that.
That was good stuff.
Oh, man. All right. Here we go.
Abbi, Questlove,
these next clues are for you.
-The password is...
-Questlove, why don't you
start us off this time?
Since you didn't have
a chance to go.
-Oh!
[ Laughter ]
Philly...
-East Point.
-Suburbs.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, that's it! That's it!
-Oh, wow!
No, it's not it.
-I got it, I got it, I got it.
-"Suburbs." Yeah.
Judges, can we accept?
No, of course we can't. Yeah.
[ Buzzer ]
Okay.
-Um...
Thing?
[ Laughter ]
-What?
-Philly. Thing.
-Cheesesteak.
-I agree.
-Slang.
-Jawn.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Jawn.
-Aww! I would've known...
-I would have said "jam."
All right. Here we go.
Our final clue goes to
Rocky and Tariq right there.
Here you go.
-The password is...
-ASAP, why don't you
start us off?
Here we go.
Oh, eye contact has begun.
They're in the zone.
Auto Zone.
-Fangs.
-Fangs?
-Oh. Fangs.
Vampire.
[ Laughter ]
-Ready?
-Yeah.
-[ Transylvanian accent ]
Blood!
[ Laughter ]
-He's pointing again.
-Blood? Oh! Dracula.
-Yes!
-You got it!
♪♪
They're like --
They grew up together.
-The password is..."bubble."
-Taraji, why don't you
start us off?
-Okay.
Everything's a hint.
This is all good.
I'm feeling this. Yep.
You got this.
-Gum.
[ Laughter ]
-Blow?
-Ooh!
Quest.
-Burst.
-Bubble.
-Ohh!
[ Bell dinging ]
-Oh, my gosh!
-He said, "Ssss-Bubble."
He said the "S" on the beginning
of it. "S-bubble."
Like s'more.
-Jimmy and Tariq.
Give that to Tariq.
-I see what's going on.
-The password is...
-Tariq, you're up first.
[ Laughter ]
-Ya.
[ Applause ]
-Ay?
[ Laughter ]
-Good answer. Good answer.
-Ohh!
-"Ohh."
Hold it. Just hold it.
Hold it. Be cool. Jimmy?
-Shake.
-Shimmy.
-Ohh!
[ Bell dinging ]
-[ Speaking indistinctly ]
-It is a barn burner!
-Shimmy! Shimmy for Jimmy!
The score -- The score --
The score is Sammy Hagar. 55.
-Uh-oh.
-Alright.
-Whew!
-The password is...
-Quest. Quest, you start us off.
-Okay.
-Yeah. I'm not looking.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
-Oh, God.
[ Laughter ]
-He's doing his De Niro.
Oh, no. He's doing his De Niro.
-He's doing an impression.
-Gabagool!
[ Laughter ]
-Is that hyphenated?
"Gabagool"?
-Oh, God. Uh...
-Gabagool!
-"Sopranos"?
-"Sopranos." No.
-Ugh!
-Not "Sopranos." Okay.
Gabagool.
-How do I do this?
Uh...
Hmm.
I don't. know.
This is hard. Help me.
-No!
-Come on. You can do this.
-I can do this?
-Yeah. It's easy.
I got it. Gabagool. I know that.
-Hoagie.
-Hoagie?
-Sub?
-Ooh.
No. Down to 4 points.
-Pastrami...
[ Laughter ]
-You got this.
-Finish his sentence, obviously.
-Pastrami...
-And rye?
-Oh.
-No.
-Alright. Down to 3 points.
[ Laughter ]
Pastrami and rye.
-He's not wrong.
-Not wrong. Close.
Alright, Taraji, you got it.
-Sandwich.
-Hoagie. Pastrami. Sandwich.
Gabagool.
-Unh! Pastrami.
-You know thisssss.
-Hey, no cheating!
-I'm not cheating!
-You can't use magic!
-Uh...
-Hm!
-Deli?
-No.
-2 points. 2 points.
-Meat.
-Salami.
-Ohh!
[ Bell dinging ]
Ohh! Okay.
Final clue.
-No!
-7 to 5.
How did they get it? Magic.
Jimmy.
-The password is...
-We got to win.
We got to beat --
-Okay, Jimmy.
You're gonna start us off.
-I go first.
Okay. Here we go.
-You got this one.
-It's you and I together.
-Come on. You got this one.
You can do it.
-I dropped my --
-Can I -- I can't.
-Yeah, you can.
-Okay.
-Uh...
sing.
[ Audience groans ]
-Man, they turned on you quick.
-They turned on me. But --
-What is it? Sing?
-Sing.
-I know. It's a bad clue.
You can't...
-Who said?
-I looked at the judges.
They said no.
-You can't?
-I didn't look at the judges.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, hit that buzzer
when he says it!
-You can't.
You can't. You can't.
-Okay.
-Song?
-No.
-It's alright.
We can get it. We can get it.
-Don't you dare, man.
[ Laughter ]
♪ Ricola ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Shouts ]
-Echo?
-Ohh!
-[ Yodeling ]
Oh, Jimmy!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Ohh!
-Wait. She hasn't got it yet.
-Spell that.
-Yee-yee.
-Swedish.
-Ohh.
[ Sad tuba plays ]
-What's this?!
-Oh, no.
-[ Yodeling ]
-Yodel.
[ Bell dinging ]
-The winners! The winners!